if i input myself into an autoencoder
it can create a pretty good al though
not perfect
reconstruction of me
why don't i uh well i mean you explain
sure so look auto encoders are an
unsupervised neural network and they
consist of two parts let's let's take a
look there is first of all an encoder
that's
the first layer
and that takes in some input
and learns how to efficiently compress
and encode that data into something that
we call
the code
then we have a decoder that learns how
to reconstruct that encoded data
representation so
decoder
and that creates
output
and that output is as similar to the
original input data as possible
effectively an autoencoder learns to
recognize which aspects of observable
data are relevant and limit noise in
data that can be discarded separate the
signal
from the noise
okay great so is this is this all about
creating smaller file sizes like the way
i'll zip up some documents or compressor
video no not at all
so let's talk about some examples
convolutional autoencoders have a
variety of use cases related to images
so for example i can draw an image like
this number three
and then through a process called
feature extraction i can derive the
required features of the image by
removing noise
something that looks a bit more like
this
and then i'm able to generate an output
that approximates the original
it's not exactly the same
but it's pretty close
now i can use this part called the code
to do other things like create a higher
resolution version of the output image
or i can colorize an image so black and
white input full color output
now in this case the input and the
output they look much the same which
well that's what autoencoders are all
about but they don't have to be
we can provide input to an auto encoder
in a corrupted form like the noisy image
of a of a 3
and then train a denoising auto encoder
to reconstruct our original image from
the noisy version of it
once we've trained our auto encoder to
remove noise from a representation of a
number or a picture or
park bench
we can apply that to all sorts of
objects within an object element that
displayed the same noise pattern
so let's take a closer look inside an
auto encoder
the encoder itself compresses the input
into a latent space representation so
we have multiple layers here
that represent
the encoder
each one a little smaller than the other
so this part here that's the
encoder
the most compressed version we said
that's called the code that's also known
as the bottle neck because i suppose
much like the neck of a bottle that's
the most compressed part
then we have the decoder
which is reconstructed
from that bottleneck
that's the decoder
and it's reconstructed from the latent
space representation to generate the
output
by learning what makes up the signal and
what makes up the noise we also have the
ability to detect when something is not
part of the status quo and that's
anomaly detection anomalies are a
significant deviation from the general
behavior of the data and auto encoders
are very good at telling us when
something doesn't fit
as a result auto encoders are widely
used in anomaly detection in things such
as fault
fraud and intrusion detection
so auto encoders are a great way of
extracting noise
recognizing relevant features and
detecting anomalies a pretty handy
toolbox for dealing with all sorts of
data
and
eerily similar clones
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching